do
and you make dessert Nikolai's rising
above Europe's spaceport in French
Guiana Pepe Colombo begins its five
billion mile journey to mercury the
four-ton spacecraft and he just fitted
inside the shell of the Ariane rocket
it'll remain in orbit around the earth
for several weeks while Mission Control
prepares it for the seven-year journey
to the closest planet to the Sun it will
have to resist our Stars strong gravity
all the way is a controlled fall towards
the Sun but we need to slow down
dramatically actually to get there we do
planetary swim buys we use electric
propulsion which is a novelty for us
once we get to mercury we have to fly in
this environment first delivering a
Japanese spacecraft around the planet
then actually moving our spacecraft down
to a lower orbit so it's a very complex
mission
the two orbiters will study Mercury's
structure and its magnetic field the
planet is something of a mystery because
it's hard to see from Earth to earlier
NASA missions revealed a heavily
cratered planet with temperatures
exceeding 400 degrees there's evidence
from the messenger mission the previous
mission to mercury that has discovered
that there in the permanently shadowed
craters at the pole there's evidence for
water ice which is intriguing given that
we're talking about the planet that's so
close to the center of our solar system
in the Sun and it's such an extremely
challenging environment in terms of the
temperature it's then very surprising
that you would find ice engineers have
covered the spacecraft in a
hand-stitched insulating blanket with
seventy two layers of aluminium plastic
and ceramic which should help keep the
delicate electronics at room temperature
bepi is designed to operate for at least
a year and could find clues to how
mercury formed and how it survives in an
orbit so perilously close to the Sun
Tamas more Sky News